[Music]
sometimes you just need to break from
social media and other times you want
that break to be permanent the good
thing is you can deactivate your
instagram and facebook accounts using
the apps and on a web browser if you
know where to look i'm here to show you
how and i'm focusing on these two apps
owned by meta because they're the most
popular but first here's what you really
need to know before you obliterate
everything
[Music]
right now deleting your facebook account
means that you'll lose access to any of
your vr products that are linked to your
oculus which we now call meta quest it
also means that you will lose all your
vr games at least until you can hop into
the metaverse without linking a facebook
account i have no idea where i'm talking
to but if you're like me an even bigger
loss would be access to the third party
services that let you use your facebook
login to sign up or to sign in
you might have done this with spotify
and pinterest so that you don't have to
create new logins and passwords both
companies have ways for you to unlink
your facebook account but you have to do
that either on their website or on a
desktop app for others facebook says you
might have to contact those services
directly to try to unlink those accounts
one thing you should do before deleting
your facebook is go into your settings
and look for the apps and websites tab
to see a list of the services you're
signed into that way you at least know
what services to unlink
you can click remove and facebook says
it'll notify the company that your login
connection was removed but it's up to
the company to offer you another way to
log in now how to get rid of that
facebook account
facebook buried the deactivation
settings pretty deeply in its app to
permanently delete your facebook account
on your smartphone go to settings and
privacy
personal and account information account
ownership and control and then
deactivation and deletion oh so many
steps thankfully on instagram it's a lot
easier on the app tap settings account
delete account and boom just like that
it's gone
[Music]
getting rid of your social media account
is quite a commitment and so if you just
want to kind of tiptoe into that there
are ways you can get rid of your account
temporarily so how would you do that on
facebook tap this little circle if you
just want to take a temporary break aka
deactivate your account
on instagram to disable it temporarily
you have to do that from a web browser
sign in hit edit profile then scroll
down
and click here to temporarily take a
break from instagram
you can download a copy of your facebook
and instagram data so you don't lose any
memories
on your facebook account go to your
settings click
your facebook information and then
download a copy of your information
enter your email address and facebook
will send you a file with your photos
comments and profile information you can
do the same for instagram go to your
settings
then find privacy and security and
scroll down until you see
data download and request a download
once your accounts are gone go ahead and
delete the apps too
will that do anything to all the data
that meta gathered from you over the
years
no
but it will free up some space on your
phone and probably some space in your
life too
if you like content like this i'm going
to be posting more of it so subscribe to
stay in the loop and comment below and
let me know what questions you think i
should answer next until next time